react.js is elegant and minimal on the
service just write a javascript function
to represent a component that
automatically renders when your data
changes it's simple but also misleading
in reality react is a highly complex ui
library with a good amount of technical
baggage that has accumulated over the
last decade many newer frameworks
attempt to do things better but react is
still the king and if you want to be a
web developer in 2022 it's a very good
idea to learn it the problem is that
react is unopinionated yet provides many
different ways to solve the same
problems that leaves us developers with
plenty of room to screw things up with
our own stupid ideas in today's episode
of code this not that we'll look at 10
anti-patterns in react along with tips
and tricks to improve our code and also
prepare for a front-end technical
interview before we get started i have
an announcement i'm working on a brand
new course for pro members that teaches
the fundamentals of react in my 100
seconds of code format then puts those
concepts to use by building multiple
full stack applications from scratch the
course is not finished yet but i'll be
releasing new videos for it every couple
days on fire ship i o when i initially
start building a react app i usually
start by writing one big giant component
often in the app component provided by
create react app and that's intentional
because i usually don't know how i want
my code to be organized initially and i
don't want to waste my time over
organizing things before i even know
what i want to do however this results
in an anti-pattern of having one overly
large deeply nested component a
component like this is hard to
understand refactor and test we can
improve this code by refactoring into
reusable components like this navbar
could easily be broken down into one or
more components that better represent
what it does now that may sound like a
lot of work but luckily there's a vs
code extension called glean that can
leverage the ide to do this work for us
install it then highlight the code you
want to extract into its own component
click the light bulb and you'll see a
bunch of options to refactor like render
conditionally or extract component and
give it a name then it will
automatically move the code while
including the required props it's a
massive time saver that i couldn't
imagine living without now when you
start refactoring a large component you
might be tempted into another
anti-pattern of nesting components in
this example we've defined a child
component that lives inside the parent
component the child uses a function
defined in the parent and by defining it
here we don't need to provide a prop for
that function it feels very intuitive
and it works perfectly fine but there's
a major problem here every time the
parent component is rendered it will
also redefine the child component which
means it gets a new memory address and
that could lead to performance issues
and unpredictable behavior the solution
is to either not define a child
component at all or to move the child
component out of the parent and pass the
function in as a prop this example
demonstrates how react is very simple on
the surface but if you don't know
exactly what's going on it's easy to
shoot yourself in the foot here's a
similar example of a component that does
too much work and might end up causing
performance issues let's imagine we have
a component with two different pieces of
state on one piece of state we need to
run an expensive calculation anytime the
value changes the problem with our
current implementation is that any time
the state changes on this component it
will rerun the expensive calculation
even though it only depends on the one
count value it's not very obvious but
you have a potential performance
bottleneck here in a situation like this
you'll want to use the use memo hook
what it will do is remember the last
value and only run the actual function
when its dependent data changes you
might also run into the situation when
working with functions and for that
react provides a used callback hook now
another thing you might run into is that
when defining a brand new component you
get an error when trying to return two
sibling elements together that's because
every component can have only one root
element so what you might do is wrap it
with a div that works perfectly fine but
it leads to a bunch of unnecessary divs
in your markup and that can cause issues
with accessibility and css styling to
address this concern react has a
built-in fragment component or better
yet you can use the shorthand syntax of
an empty element which tells react to
render nothing as the parent element now
as your app grows in complexity and you
start creating more and more components
you'll want to have an opinionated way
to organize them a good rule to follow
is one component per file it can be
tempting to export multiple components
from a single file but things will get
pretty complicated quickly if a
component is going to be exported it's
generally best that it lives in its own
file now in larger projects i would take
things one step further and give every
component its own directory if you name
the file index then you can easily
export it from that directory but inside
the directory you can add other files
like a css module for example or
anything else you might need for testing
storybook typescript and so on this is
how they do things by default in angular
and i find it works really well for
large projects now there is one drawback
when naming your component index and
that's the fact that it's kind of
confusing when working with tabs in your
ide what you can do is give your
component file a regular name then use
the index file to export it that's
called a barrel and it will keep your
imports nice and concise while also
providing a readable file name for the
ide one of the biggest problems with big
complex apps though is that they're big
and what that means is that when you
ship your app to production it'll have a
slow initial page load because it takes
a long time for the browser to download
the javascript bundle so what can we do
about that if you're using a tool like
nexjs or create react app which are
built on top of webpack it's very easy
to implement code splitting normally to
import code you use an import statement
however browsers now support dynamic
imports which allows you to load a
module asynchronously using the import
function when webpack sees that code it
automatically knows to split that code
into a different bundle which won't be
required until after the initial page
load that works fine for plain
javascript but not so much when it comes
to react components however react has a
feature to support lazy loading which is
still experimental today but it allows
you to use dynamic imports on react
components once a component is
dynamically imported you can then wrap
it in the suspense component to show a
fallback ui when it's loading now
another problem you might run into with
big projects is that you might have one
component at the very top that holds
your state but then you have a deeply
nested component that also needs to use
that state what you have to do is then
pass that state as a prop to a bunch of
intermediate components that don't
actually need it until it finally gets
to that child this is known as prop
drilling because it makes you want to
drill a hole into your brain one
solution is to bring in a state
management library like redux but that's
a heavy-handed approach when you have
global data that's used everywhere like
an authenticated user for example you
can share it everywhere with the context
api you first provide the data at a
certain point in the component tree then
any component nested under it at any
level can access that data sounds
awesome but it does come at a cost the
context api is something that you should
use sparingly because it makes your
components impossible to reuse without
having that provider as a parent most
apps only have a handful of values that
are truly global that stuff can go into
context while everything else should be
more localized prop drilling is a
vertical problem but you might also end
up with a horizontal problem called prop
plowing which is a term i just made up
what might happen is that you end up
with components that have a lot of
different props and you end up with this
long repetitive code where each prop has
the same name as the variable passed to
it when you have an object that contains
all the props that you're passing to the
child you can use the spread syntax to
pass them all at the same time that
makes your code much more concise and
personally i'm a big fan of this however
it does make your code less explicit so
i typically only recommend using it when
you have a component with a ton of props
that really justifies its use another
area where your react code can get
pretty messy is with event handlers in
jsx what happens is you might have a
function that takes the event as its
first argument but one or more other
values as secondary arguments that means
to call it you'll need to break out an
arrow function and this can get pretty
messy if used in multiple places a cool
little javascript trick here is to
create a curried function basically it's
just a function that returns another
function the outer function takes our
custom arguments while the inner
function handles the event that's passed
by default this eliminates the need to
define an arrow function for each event
not only does that make your code look a
lot cleaner but it also gives you a
legitimate use case for currying which
will impress your friends and family and
that brings us to anti-pattern number
10. when working with the u state hook
in a component it's tempting to put all
of your data in a single object it makes
the code look cleaner and may also seem
more performant because you only need to
call set state once however what you
should know is that react 18 will do
automatic batching whenever you update
the state that means calling set state
multiple times in the same function will
not trigger multiple re-renders
therefore it's not a big deal for
performance but more importantly it
makes your code difficult to extract
into a custom hook in the olden days
with react class components it was
common to organize your code into smart
components and dumb components where the
smart components control the data and
the dumb components just render ui with
props there's nothing wrong with this
pattern but nowadays it's easier to just
extract your logic into a custom hook
what i like to do is build my component
with a bunch of different stateful
values at first then if things get too
complex or i want to use that code in a
different component i extract it into my
own custom hook which itself is just a
javascript function this allows you to
treat virtually all your components as
dump components while your custom hooks
handle the more complex business logic
and with that we've looked at a small
preview of the different things you can
screw up and react check out my full
course if you want to learn more about
react and here's a special discount for
making it all the way to the end of this
video thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next one